Bueno, lo que quiero ver en este video
son ecuaciones cuadráticas o expresiones cuadráticas,
que vamos a factorizar
pero, que no tengan
como primer término "x" cuadrada a secas.
Lo que quiero es que no tenga un 1
multiplicando a la "x" cuadrada,
que tenga otro número
por ejemplo este
4x cuadrada más 25x menos 21,
si te das cuenta el número que está
al lado de la "x" cuadrada no es 1
como lo habíamos visto
en las ocasiones anteriores,
es 4,
y bueno,
¿cómo se resuelve esto?
La forma de resolver esto
es buscar otra vez dos números
pero dos números
que cumplan lo siguiente,
que la multiplicación de ambos
nos den 4 por -21,
es decir, "a" por "c",
el primer coeficiente por el último coeficiente,
o simple y sencillamente acuérdate
de que es el número que esté al lado de la "x"
por el coeficiente libre
y me va a quedar
4 por -21,
la multiplicación de esos dos números,
me tienen que dar
esta multiplicación que tengo que calcular
y después, la suma de estos dos números
me tiene que dar 25
"a" por "b"
es igual a 4 por -21,
4 por -21 que por cierto,
4 por -21 es -84
y además "a" más "b"
me tienen que dar 25
"a" más "b" tiene que ser igual al término...
al coeficiente perdón,
que está al lado de la "x",
es decir 25
y bueno
¿Quiénes son estos dos números que cumplen esto?
Si te das cuenta aquí tenemos al 4, aquí tenemos el 21, esto es lo que nunca tienes que olvidar
tenemos que multiplicar estos dos de aquí
y bueno,
¿Qué números me dan que su suma es 25
y que su multiplicación es menos -84?
Lo primero que podrás decir es que funciona con 4 y 21
sin embargo,
tiene que ser 1 positivo y 1 negativo
y 4 menos 21 me da -17
y 21 menos 4 me da 17,
por lo tanto no funciona.
Entonces tenemos que buscar
o pensar en otro par de números,
tales que sean una factorización de 84
y que su suma me den 25,
y además fíjate como el 84 es negativo,
tiene que ser uno positivo y uno negativo
entonces, 1 y 84,
1 y 84 no funciona
porque 84 menos 1 es 83
y por lo tanto esto nunca me va a dar a 25
bueno 2 y 42
2 y 42 si los resto,
me dan ó -40 ó 40 positivo
por lo tanto,
creo que tampoco es la mejor opción.
A ver vamos a ver con 3
¿3 y cuánto es 84 entre 3?
3 entre 8 me sobran dos,
a ver déjenme ver aquí
84 entre 3,
2 veces y 2 por 3 son 6
entonces le quito 6 me queda 2
y después bajó el 4
y 24 cabe 8 veces en 3,
8 por 3 = 24
por lo tanto es 3 y 28
y 28 menos 3 es 25,
perfecto, aquí están.
28 menos 3 es 25 ó 3 menos 28 me da -25
pero como yo quiero que el 25 sea positivo
entonces el 28 tiene que ser positivo,
y el 3 tiene que ser negativo
y ya encontré estos
dos números que estoy buscando.
¿Y para que los estoy buscando?
Porque fíjate
voy a escribir el término
que está justo aquí en medio,
este 25x como -3x más 28x,
pero antes me quiero fijar un poquito
en que se parece más
28 a 4 o 28 a 21.
Fíjate bien lo voy a escribir como
28x menos 3x
y después voy a poner los términos que me faltan,
este de aquí es 25x
28x menos 3x
es lo mismo que 25x
y aquí tengo 4x cuadrada
y aquí al final tengo -21,
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que yo puse el 28x
pegado al 4x cuadrada
porque el 28x se parece más al 4x cuadrada,
que lo que se parece el -3x
y de hecho el -3x se parece más al -21
que lo que se parece el 28x,
lo que estoy intentando es que se junten
términos muy parecidos,
con términos muy parecidos.
porque lo que voy a hacer a continuación es
factorizar de estos 2 lo más que se pueda,
es decir, de 4x cuadrada más 28x
voy a factorizar lo más que se pueda.
Y por otra parte, de los otros 2,
también voy a factorizar lo más que se pueda es decir,
voy a agregarle -3x menos 21 y de estos 2
voy a tratar de factorizar todo lo que sea necesario.
Y vuelvo a repetirte, fíjate que el 28
tiene más propiedades en común que el 4
es decir el 28 es divisible entre 4,
que es lo que es él 3, si yo pusiera aquí,
4x cuadrada menos 3x ,
no se ve tan fácil de factorizar todo lo que se pueda,
y de igual manera para
-3 y -21,
-3 y -21 tienen un factor común
y por lo tanto se pueden factorizar.
Bueno, entonces de los 2 primeros términos,
voy a factorizar lo más que se puede,
lo más que se puede es 4x
4x que multiplica "x" me da 4x cuadrada
y después 28x entre 4x es 7,
ó 4x por 7 me da 28x
entonces ya factoricé
lo más que se puede,
y de aquí lo más que se puede entre -3x y -21,
es un -3,
-3 que multiplica a "x"
y -3 que multiplica a 7,
-3x menos 21.
Y bueno, lo padre de este asunto es que,
"x" más 7 y "x" más 7
es de nuevo nuestro factor común
y por lo tanto lo podemos factorizar.
Recuerdas cómo se llamaba esto,
esto es la famosísima factorización por agrupación,
ya tenemos ahora aquí un grupo,
un binomio en lo cual es mi factor común,
y lo voy a factorizar de nuevo
para que quede multiplicando a otro binomio
¿A qué binomio?
Pues el binomio 4x menos 3,
así que déjenme escribirlo de esta manera,
esto lo voy a borrar
porque me queda más por menos me da -3
y simple y sencillamente
me va a quedar
"x" más 7
déjame escribirlo aquí,
es "x" más 7 que es mi factor común,
que va a multiplicar a,
4x menos 3 que son los otros 2
monomios que están multiplicando
precisamente a este "x" más 7,
"x" más 7
que multiplica a 4x menos 3,
4x menos este 3, me da 4x -3
¿y qué creen?
Ya encontré l
a solución de la factorización,
de esta expresión cuadrática que tenía aquí arriba,
que se veía bastante horrible
gracias a la factorización por agrupación,
por lo tanto yo sé que
esto es bastante confuso en un principio
y mejor vamos a trabajar
en un segundo ejemplo.
El segundo ejemplo que me quiero tomar es éste,
6x cuadrada más 7x más 1.
Y bueno
¿Cómo factorizo esta expresión?
Lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es buscar 2 números tales que
"a" por "b" sea 1 por 6 ó 6 por 1,
lo cual me da 6
y "a" más "b" sea el término
o el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x"
es decir 7,
y bueno
aquellos números cuando yo multiplicó me dan 6
y cuando yo lo sumo me dan 7,
a pues eso está muy fácil,
es 1 y 6
"a" tiene que ser igual a 1
y "b" tiene que ser igual a 6,
o mejor lo escribo de esta manera.
Esto es lo mismo que 1 y 6,
y por lo tantom yo me tengo que fijar ahora,
que 7x lo puedo escribir
como 6x más 1x
ó 6x mas "x" pero,
¿Qué es más parecido?
6x cuadrada a 6x
ó a 1x
pues te vas a dar cuenta
que es mucho más parecido a 6x,
por lo tanto,
lo voy a poner en un principio,
6x cuadrada más 6x más 1x,
¿y quién es más parecido 1x ó 6x a 1?
Y tú me vas a decir, que es más parecido 1,
por lo tanto  ya queda todo en orden.
6x cuadrada más 6x más 1x más 1,
y entonces tomo los dos primeros,
recuerda siempre hay que tomar
los dos primeros términos
y factorizar lo más que se pueda,
que por cierto es 6x,
6x que multiplica a "x" más 1
6x por "x"
me da 6x cuadrada
y 6x por 1 me da 6x
y de los otros dos términos tengo
que factorizar lo más que se pueda
pero, si te das cuenta
lo más que se puede de aquí es 1
1 que multiplica a "x" más 1
y entonces si esto tiene factorización,
te tiene que quedar un factor común en este paso,
es decir,
tenemos que encontrar un grupo
o un binomio que sea tu factor común
para terminar de utilizar la famosísima
factorización por agrupación
y aquí, pues sí lo tenemos,
tenemos que "x" más 1 es de nuevo nuestro factor común
y entonces me va a quedar "x" más 1
que multiplica a 6x por una parte y por otra parte a 1,
y ya otra vez obtuve mi resultado.
Gracias a la factorización por agrupación,
obtuve como factorizar
esta expresión de aquí arriba
que no se veía tan fácil
de factorizar en un principio,
pero seguramente
te estás preguntando
¿De dónde viene todo esto?
Así que vamos a hacer el caso general
para entender perfectamente
¿de dónde viene todo esto?
"ax" más "b"
no esperen, esperen,
es que la "a", la "b" y la "c",
no quiero que te confundas con
la "a", la "b"
que tenemos aquí arriba
por lo tanto,
déjeme escribirlo de una manera distinta
quiero ver
qué es lo que pasa con "fx" más "g",
no te asustes,
solamente me estoy tomando otro par de letras,
esto que a su vez multiplica
a "hx" más  "j"...
más "j" por que la "i" se utiliza para otras cosas,
que ya veremos en vídeos posteriores.
Y bueno pues vamos a multiplicar.
¿Qué me queda de todo esto?
"fx" por "hx"
me queda "fhx" cuadrada...
"fhx" cuadrada
y después me queda "fx" que multiplica a "j"
me queda "fjx"
y después es "g" por "hx" es "ghx"
g"hx" y después "g" por "j"
me queda "gj"...
"gj"  perfecto,
y ahora voy a factorizar
estos dos términos que están en medio,
me va a quedar lo siguiente,
"fhx" cuadrada más,
y ahora sí voy a juntar estos 2,
"fj" más "gh"
que multiplica a "x"
"fj" más "gh",
y todo esto multiplica a "x",
y a esto le sumamos más "gj"
y bueno realmente,
¿Cómo resolvemos este tipo de ejercicios?
Si nos fijamos acá arriba,
buscábamos 2 números tales que
multiplicados me dieran 6 por 1
y sumados me dieran 7,
es decir,
el término que está al lado de la "x"
y si te das cuenta,
aquí el término que este lado de la "x"
es "fj" más "gh",
entonces qué te parece,
si definimos así lo siguiente.
Voy a definir que,
"a" es igual a "fj" y "b" es igual a "gh"
entonces "a" más "b" que multiplica a "x"
es lo mismo que el fj más gh que multiplica a "x"
y entonces,
ya tenemos lo de aquí arriba,
y ahora vamos a ver cuánto es "a" por "b"
"a" por "b" es lo mismo que "fj",
"fj" que multiplica a "gh"
y esto lo podemos ordenar
de una manera distinta,
porque recuerda que el orden de los factores
no afecta el producto
cuando hablamos de números reales.
Y  y lo voy a poner como "fh"
que multiplica a "gj"
lo único que estoy haciendo es utilizando
la propiedad conmutativa de la multiplicación,
y bueno, esto lo puedo ver como "fh"
que multiplica a su vez a "gj"
¿y quién es esto?
Si te das cuenta es el primer término
que teníamos aquí,
el que estaba multiplicando
a "x" cuadrada,
y el último término que tengo aquí,
el que está como coeficiente libre,
como término libre
y entonces,
ya llegamos a lo que queríamos.
Es justo por esta razón que está funcionando
nuestra factorización por agrupación,
porque buscamos dos números
que multiplicados me den,
el primer término
y el último término,
y que a su vez sumados me den el término,
que está al lado de la "x".
Así que vamos a hacer en esta ocasión
un ejercicio un poco más difícil,
y no quiero que te espantes,
de hecho tal vez lo veas y digas
¡Oh! Este ejercicio es demasiado obvio,
es muy fácil resolverlo
pero quiero aumentarle
un poquito de nivel a este ejercicio,
aunque tal vez en un futuro,
haga un vídeo de solamente ejercicios de este estilo.
Vamos a ver el siguiente caso,
se me ocurre ponerte -x cubica
y a esto le voy a sumar
17x cuadrada y después le voy a quitar menos 70x
y seguramente,
lo primero que me vas a decir es
¡Oye Sal yo no tengo ni idea
de cómo resolver este polinomio!
Porque si te das cuenta no es un polinomio cuadrático, es un polinomio cúbico,
pero, lo primero que quiero que veas
es que todo es divisible entre "x", por lo tanto
podemos sacar como factor común a "x"
o mejor a -x,
-x va a ser factor común y entonces -x cúbica entre - "x" me da "x" cuadrada positiva
después 17x cuadrada entre "-x"
me da -17x
y después me queda,
-70x entre "-x" me da más 70.
Y ahora que ya tenemos factorizada la "-x",
vamos a fijarnos en lo que está dentro del paréntesis,
si te das cuenta
lo que está dentro del paréntesis es así,
es una ecuación cuadratica
y vamos a ver si la podemos factorizar.
Buscamos 2 números,
que multiplicados me den 70 positivo
y que sumados me den -17
y eso está muy fácil,
seguramente se te ocurre
que es -10 y -7
y en efecto es -10 y -7,
porque -10 por -7 me da más 70 positivo
y -10 menos 7
me da -17x,
por lo tanto,
eso lo podemos escribir como "x" menos 10,
que multiplica a "x" menos 7
y todo esto por "-x"
que era la "-x" del principio
¡y qué crees!
Ya factorizamos esta expresión que era cúbica
y además,
que decías que no estaba tan fácil de factorizar,
realmente no fue tan difícil,
pero bueno,
en fin, realmente lo que quiero que veas
y lo que quería enseñarte en este video,
era a factorizar expresiones
de este estilo,
donde no tenemos al lado
de la "x" cuadrada un 1
como siempre lo habíamos visto,
tenemos otra cosa
y ahora ya sabes factorizarlo
en un tiempo no muy largo.